I remember years ago I took the course
it was a funny course - it was called
forensic pathology if you can imagine
and it was taught by if you can imagine
Sacha Shulgin forensic pathology right
so one of the things he did in this
class is he brought in a little vial of
some substance and there were 500 people
in this class it was a cow so we passed
it around no big deal you sniff it a
kind of a nondescript
odor pass it on to the next person out
of the 500 people three had an
incredibly violent reaction to this
stuff and then Sasha explained there is
a known gene for reacting to this thing
people who have this gene are 50,000
times more sensitive to this substance
than people without it well just
extrapolate that range to every
substance in nature and and you will see
why in a sense learning what drugs you
should and shouldn't take is as big a
task as deciding what kind of person you
should or shouldn't go to bed with what
kind of investments you should or
shouldn't make in other words it's a
lifetime task of mistake making learning
self observation and correction and
what's what's sauce for the goose may
not be sauce for the gander and you have
to honor your individuality people the
shamans say you know if the plant wants
you it will take you you you will know
if if there is the lock and key fit
there is a great deal to be learned
emulating plans especially in the
culture of crisis that we're in first of
all plan they have to deal with their
toxic byproducts because they can't move
away from them the way we do and move
into new niches plants are homeostatic
ly self-regulating plants are small
solar factories essentially plants do
all their work at temperatures below a
hundred and fifteen degrees notice that
we do our tech our technologies operate
at 600 degrees and up and then produce
all kinds of heavy metal toxins and
poisons and this sort of thing also in a
sense the Dow like passivity of plans
the way in which they accept their
circumstances essentially an animal is
is an organism that can move away from
the circumstances of its own being and
so for all of these reasons plants seem
like an excellent model for the kind of
future that we should be building we
want to go to lower energy we want to go
to more organic starting and
materials in industrial processes we
want to create a kind of integrated
homeostatic cohesion in our society in
all these cases and a solar based
society in all these cases the plans
provide the model they've been showing
how to do these things and very
efficiently for a very long time I think
you know as we learn from the plant the
plants learn from us in some tips when
you take the plant it takes you
[Music]